dans ce laboratoire de l'hôpital de
chicoutimi on garde la quasi-totalité
des tests positifs à la coved du québec
on utilise cette banque pour faire du
séquençage génomique en vain lire lettre
par lettre les trente mille lettres qui
contient le code génétique de virus et
voit où il ya des changements sont donc
c'est vraiment oui la carte d'identité
de chaque virus et ça on peut le faire
uniquement avec la génomique
cette technologie a permis de détecter
entre autres le variant britannique qui
inquiète
il ya déjà des études qui montrent
qu'ils aient les autos des 40 50 % plus
transmissible que les autres variantes
qu'on avait vu à 20 depuis le printemps
les scientifiques surveillent
l'apparition de variants je le regrette
pas on va être en mesure de détecter les
variations rapides
le gouvernement du québec vient
d'annoncer 11 millions de dollars pour
accélérer la cadence du séquençage et
toi pour cent des champions alors 3%
c'est pas un nombre élevé donc la
couverture vous serez dans les mois et
est minimal mais annonce du gros match
ouvert on a 10% midi champions ce qui
correspond au double de la moyenne
canadienne qui est de 5 % la moyenne
américaine et de -2 1%
l'ontario enregistre le plus grand
nombre de cas actifs au canada et aussi
le plus grand nombre d'infections
variant britannique
on parle désormais de propagation
communautaire et on se prépare au pire
au québec on s'inquiète moins de
l'arrivée d'une troisième vague
le nombre de cas d'infections aux
variants britannique est très faible
la province a déjà préparé sa riposte
acheter une image si elle va rien à part
et ne pas relâcher les mesures de
prévention mais qu'au climat ici au smic
hayat radio canada montréal